it's time for the weekly mail bag if you
have something you want to say to me and
many of you do
you can email info davidpakman.com
please don't abuse it but you can do
that you can email info at
davidpakman.com let's get right in we're
going to start with a very very ugly
message this one actually came in via
facebook this was a response to
uh our clip last week about evolution
you might remember that republican
senate candidate herschel walker last
week said if evolution is real why are
there still monkeys
and we talked about that last week now
this viewer wrote to me
very angry
making the following counterpoint think
about water
were did it came from or did it also
evolved
and you know i never have considered the
evolution of water in this entire
crazy thing we called life i don't i
don't have an answer to that
this person also went on two hours later
to write and say as a follow-up in all
caps
jehovah is the name of the creator
whether you believe it or not just
because you may not like it doesn't mean
is not true
so uh quite a diatribe
from
the standpoint of the evolution of water
and this of course a reminder that
education is really a problem in the
united states if we had
a solution to the education problem
we would be much better off politically
we would be much better off culturally
and we would be much better off
economically i would argue so there it
is the evolution of water not something
i had thought about before
john wrote in
and john said hey pacman or pac-man
whatever
i am expressing my opinion here as a
viewer
you have a horrible stupid show
stop broadcasting now
stop wasting your time
get a real life
and grow up uh i actually i love these
emails and the reason i love these
emails and i know there are people in
our audience who like the show and who
are miserable in their jobs and i don't
take any pleasure in that i like that
makes me feel bad i want everybody to
have a job they like and that's
sustainable financially and all these
different things one of the things i
love
is people who are very clearly not
satisfied with their own lives
write to me and say
you got to get a real job you gotta you
gotta get a real life you've gotta grow
up etc this job is fine i i am i love
the hours
uh i'm very satisfied with the salary
i'm very satisfied with the meaning of
what i'm doing and it's just so funny to
hear from other people who are clearly
miserable in their lives which in many
cases is what causes them to lash out at
random people on the internet that they
don't know
uh
there's something funny
about them saying to me
you gotta get your life together
together kid so anyway thank you john i
appreciate the the message okay
p samuels wrote in this is the last
negative one then we're gonna go to
positive and substantive stuff i very
seldom write to shows on tv or otherwise
i guess i'm lucky in that way
david pakman
is a true low iq imbecile do us all a
favor and ask him
to keep his mouth shut
there is so much dribble coming forth
from his mouth
it is beyond disgusting well thank you
sir i will keep that in mind i guess i
should really reconsider
this show it seems like at least two
people
very very much don't like it that's p
samuels all right let's get into some
other stuff
um oh
sorry i apologize
there's one more negative one and this
this so here's the point with this one
we covered trump's last rally and
excuse me choking here i'm gonna take a
sip of water
we covered trump's last rally in south
carolina
and i mentioned on twitter
that trump was particularly disheveled
slurring
confused both eyes almost completely
swollen shut
and it seemed that a lot of his
followers realized it was not a great
performance
but they decided to take it out on me
they were furious with me
for my commentary on the rally
newpont wrote to me and said about the
rally
david you are disgusting
you are an arrogant ignorant fool
sucking up to the likes of nancy pelosi
chuck schumer the squad and the rest of
the socialist elite in washington now
what i love about that
is
i'm not a fan of nancy pelosi's
i can't remember the last time i spoke
about chuck schumer
i can't remember the last time i praised
the squad and i'm not a socialist so i
actually don't know what this person's
talking about but doesn't matter here's
the amazing part of the email i watched
the trump rally
the man is brilliant
you were an idiot and a fool and your
snide little snippets during the
president's presentation exuded and
reeked of your ignorance and arrogance
go drown yourself in the swamp of
washington dc i have never watched your
show had never even heard of you until i
watched this rally on your channel and i
will never ever in the history of the
world watch you again you are a sick man
here's what i would say to you sir
anyone who believes trump is brilliant
should not like my show i would consider
it a problem i would be concerned if
someone who thinks trump is brilliant
liked what i was doing it i consider it
praise it is confirmation that i'm doing
something right
that people who think trump is brilliant
don't like me that's a great thing thank
you sir i appreciate that okay david
wrote in with some ideas for an
alternative to screed
um back in february i would often
describe trump's unhinged rants as
febrile screeds david wrote in and said
i've noticed you keep referring to
various wacky or delusional rants by
right-wing politicians as screeds for
example donald trump's latest febrile
screed perhaps a distinction without a
difference but technically screed refers
to a written rant not a spoken one as
you mean to say there are a number of
alternatives you can test out including
diatribe
tirade and polemic
in all seriousness thanks for calling
out the buffoonery of these right-wing
radicals when they issue such febrile
screeds
with peace and love yeah i had something
like for march since it has an m
uh i i think i i was it was a manic
what was it manic i don't remember now
anyway i'll work on something else uh
maybe a uh
maybe a delusional diatribe would be
some appropriate alliteration
another david wrote in dave who says
david you mentioned that the democracy
rating of ukraine is 60 and russia is
20. where does the united states fit on
the same scale so
that particular ranking was from the
freedom house
and in that freedom house index the u.s
ranks at an 82
on the democracy rank ranking so in that
one it's u.s 82 ukraine 60 russia 20.
now i think that there is a case to be
made
that
in the united states
people are less free than in some other
countries in a particular way and that
is the ability
to live your life the way you want
without worrying about having medical
coverage that's not typically considered
in most of these kind of like freedom
and democracy rankings
i would argue and i would argue it very
strongly
that
if you
know that no matter what you do you have
medical care
you are more free to pursue
a passion that may not come with health
insurance and the job that you would
tend to have to have to get health
insurance you are free to
stay home and raise children without
having to worry about will i have health
insurance so that's not typically part
of these freedom and democracy rankings
i believe it should be because in
countries where you are guaranteed
health care regardless of your job you
are more free in a sense although i
understand that it's a little bit
different than issues of corruption and
the like but in the freedom house index
uh the u.s ranks at 82
compared to ukraine 60 and russia 20.
brian writes in and says i have enjoyed
watching some of your youtube pieces i
have a suggestion
say electoral instead of electoral
see what you think keep calm and carry
on so i i again i look this up and this
is going to relate to a later
a later email
um i am finding that both pronunciations
electoral and electoral
are both appropriate
electoral comes more naturally to me and
i don't know if it's that i i speak
english as a second language or what but
electoral
just feels more natural okay sherry
wrote in asking is the white house
beautiful or is it a dump
david go back and look at videos from
when trump first won in 2016 and went to
the white house he called the white
house a dump now he says it's beautiful
the beautiful white house what a schmuck
he is as bad as hitler disgusting human
being thanks
keep up the good work yeah i mean listen
the guy's a total hypocrite um the you
know putin's good or putin's bad
ukraine's good or ukraine's bad he will
uh build the wall or not or he'll
replace obamacare or he won't or it's it
it doesn't matter it doesn't matter what
he says
we don't really know what he believes i
believe he basically believes nothing he
believes whatever is convenient to say
at the time
but yeah and i actually remember the
opposite also because there were times
while trump was there
that he called the white house beautiful
and then now that biden's there
says that it's a dump and it's been
disgraced or whatever sherry i just
wouldn't worry about it don't worry
about what trump says on the white house
last email is from kate
kate says you might want to be careful
citing a dictionary as a prescriptive
reference this is a common error a
dictionary is a descriptive tool not a
prescriptive one it describes the
language that existed at the time of
publication using the dictionary to say
the dictionary says x means y isn't
helpful the dictionary doesn't tell
people what to use now it tells you what
people used then well i mean listen
that's totally fair when i say
i looked up the acceptable
pronunciations of such a word and here's
what the dictionary says
you could say well those were acceptable
at the time the dictionary was written
but i think that that actually sort of
goes to my point which is absent that
then any pronunciation would be
acceptable because at the end of the day
it's just what people are doing it would
be you you would better be able to
justify no no the
pronunciation of electoral is
appropriate because it's what i use
it's kind of an endless loop so i think
when it comes to accepted pronunciations
it i i think it's okay to look at the
dictionary um
but i do understand how
looking at the dictionary for
definitions like you know when jesse lee
peterson said to me what is a man
the dictionary may not reflect
the political and cultural realities of
the time i think that that's fair
and i appreciate the comment from kate
we have a great voice we have a great
bonus show coming up you can sign up at
joinpackman.com to get instant access
we will see you then